good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight i'm jesse waters in for
tucker we've learned a lot about joe
biden in the last year for one we know
he's not the same old
scranton joe that represented delaware
in the senate for decades or the old
tough guy joe who saved the day by
fighting off corn pop he's not even the
same joe biden who is barack obama's
vice president that joe biden is gone
and he's been gone for a while
in 2021 biden confirmed what many of us
could see during the presidential
campaign he is decaying that is not an
attack on biden he's nearly 80 years old
anyone who's watched joe biden can see
it
it's a fact we take no pleasure in
stating nobody is happy when the
president united states stumbles over
his words or forgets where he is we
don't enjoy watching him fall asleep in
the middle of an overseas summit but his
decline is hard to ignore
his latest example came just last night
in an interview with abc news
joe biden struggled to remember the name
of the latest covet variant called
omicron
but maybe that's not exactly a surprise
since joe biden also told us
he didn't even see omicron coming
the vice president said in recent days
that that you didn't see delta coming
you didn't see omicron coming
how did you get it wrong
i didn't get it wrong nobody saw it
coming
nobody in the whole world who saw it
the omicron variant has been around for
weeks the world health organization
announced its existence in late november
and the us government designated it as a
concern days later but somehow joe biden
missed all of that if the president of
the united states acknowledging he was
completely unaware of the incoming
coveted variants wasn't bad enough
biden then confused coronavirus tests
with pills
he sounded like he had no idea what he
was talking about as he frequently does
and then he told us the lack of
available coronavirus tests for the
variant he also tells us we're supposed
to be scared of isn't a failure
you told the american people just
yesterday that we are prepared for
what's coming
but three days before christmas if you
look out across the country you see it
everywhere these long lines people
waiting for hours outside in the cold
just to get tested empty shelves no test
kits is that a failure no i don't think
it's a failure i think it's uh
you could argue that we should have
known
a year ago six months ago two months ago
a month ago i've ordered half a billion
of the pills
500 million pills i'm excuse me 500
million test kits that are going to be
available to be sent to every home in
america if anybody wants them but
the answer is yeah i wish i had thought
about ordering a half a billion pills
two months ago before covet hit here
that is who has the final say on public
health in this country a man who can't
differentiate between tests and pills or
delta and omicron the same joe biden who
told us earlier this year vaccines
prevent transmission quote you're not
gonna
get covered
if you have these vaccinations unquote
that's who's at the helm
americans expect the leader of the free
world to inspire confidence heading into
the new year
instead joe biden confessed that nothing
has been good enough
and in what was likely his last
interview before millions of americans
hoped to gather for christmas joe biden
told the country that only vaccinated
americans are permitted to celebrate one
of our nation's most sacred holidays
we're nearly two years into this
pandemic you're a year into the
presidency
empty shelves and no test kits in some
places three days before christmas when
it's so important
is that good enough
no nothing's been good enough
but look who we are if you are tested if
you know where you are in terms of
having gotten the shots there's no
reason why you can't get together with
your family and your friends
and
we couldn't do that last christmas
if we learned anything new about joe
biden last night it's this
a year of failures and errors on
everything from the economy to lockdowns
and mandates the border and afghanistan
have all taken their toll
joe biden is completely dejected and he
knows it
and if there was ever any doubt about
biden's health or cognitive ability he
put that all to rest yesterday biden
actually admitted his own health was a
legitimate question
we don't have to guess anymore joe biden
says his health could prevent him from
running for re-election in 2024
i want to ask you about something i
asked weeks before the election when we
sat down
you said you would absolutely serve
eight years if elected do you plan to
run for re-election yes
but look
i'm a great respecter of fate
fate has intervened in my life many many
times
if i'm in the health i'm in now
if i'm in good health
then in fact i would run again and if
that means a rematch against donald
trump
you're trying to tempt me now
sure
why would i not run against donald trump
or the nominee that increased the
prospect of running
we can't think of any other time where a
president has speculated about the
decline of his own health
what's worse is joe biden thinks his
current state is the definition of good
health
but he isn't fooling anybody we see it
the american people see it and surely
his staff sees it too
it's why they usually keep him on a very
tight script he's only allowed to speak
to reporters when they give him
permission he hardly gives any
interviews and last night showed exactly
why joe biden can't speak without
embarrassing himself and his own
administration the white house knows all
of that and yet they send him out anyway
why
because his opportunist handlers who
helped make him the president want you
to know he's inept
they want to make it clear joe biden's
not running things
and that they're the ones with the real
power
they're trying to accelerate the
argument that he needs to be replaced
cnn put it very clearly in a headline
this week quote the 11 democrats who
could replace joe biden in 2024.
what's interesting is that even other
democrats are being challenged about joe
biden's ability to lead kamala harris
was asked about this just a few days ago
and she pretended to be very angry
okay so who's the real president of this
country is it joe manchin or joe biden
madam vice president come on charlemagne
i really don't it's joe buddy i can't
tell sometimes no no no no
it's joe biden and don't start talking
like a republican about asking whether
or not he's president do you think joe
manchin is a problem
it's joba and it's joe biden and i'm
vice president my name is kamala harris
did you notice how kamala had to state
that she was vis vice president almost
like she needed to remind us
that's because kamala harris is an
afterthought she was an afterthought in
the primaries when she was the first
democrat to drop out of the running
nobody liked her then
and we know with certainty nobody likes
her now her approval rating is less than
30 percent and her staffers can't quit
fast enough
so this is the state of the country and
the democratic party after joe biden's
first year in office it's a very chaotic
christmas and there's no leader to be
found
one year down
three to go